e aí
e vamos dar uma volta no futuro
e eu prometo que eu trago todo mundo de
volta antes do próximo palestrante quem
quiser voltar claro
e a transformação digital
é algo novo uma mudança profunda ampla e
rápida
o que vai causar a mudança de muitos
paradigmas muito do que a gente conhece
hoje como verdade ali na frente vai
voltar a zero e todo mundo vai ter que
reaprender
é massa esse negócio de revolução não é
novo se a gente buscar nas nossas aulas
de história a gente vai ver que já
passou por isso pelo menos umas três
vezes a primeira revolução industrial
que aconteceu na inglaterra lá no século
18.740 onde a gente altera toda a
modalidade do trabalho artesanal onde
homens mulheres crianças fabricavam tudo
aquilo que a gente precisava em oficinas
nos fundos das suas propriedades e
e depois eu ia segunda revolução
industrial que mais ficou isso
globalizou a produção em massa
a ver com isso a nível mundial a
terceira revolução lá na no século 20
chamada revolução informacional plaza
eletrônica para dentro dos processos
industriais e agora a gente chega
naquilo que chama a quarta revolução
industrial a indústria 4.0 manufatura
avançada
os nomes têm aos montes
e essa revolução vem
dá para parar de de abordar uma era de
mudanças e começar a trabalhar uma
verdadeira mudança de era
e essa revolução das tecnologias das
mais diversas algumas que talvez não tão
não são novidade para muita gente a
simulação computacional por exemplo que
já existe há anos e que a gente usa para
simular melhorias que a gente realiza
nos processos das empresas e dali
ficastes vai fazer sentido ou não
a automação que faz máquinas trabalharem
sozinhas a robótica que faz com que
roubou substituir o trabalho humano
é isso já conhecido isso já existe mas
ela traz também um conjunto de
tecnologias absolutamente novas a
internet das coisas por exemplo
e essa tecnologia vai fazer com que as
máquinas conversem entre si e com a
gente essa tecnologia vai fazer com que
o que tu conhece sobre controle remoto
mude totalmente
é aquele conjunto de controle plástico
que tu tem na tua casa vai ser tudo para
o colocado agora no teu celular porque
eles vão conversar a tua geladeira em
pouco tempo vai fazer o pedido daquilo
que tá faltando para o supermercado da
tua preferência e o supermercado vai te
entregar e talvez por algum motivo tu
até fique sabendo que aquela compra
aconteceu talvez quando conferir a
fatura do cartão de crédito
e a gente tem ainda um negócio chamado
big data
é um grande conjunto de dados
tô bem sim comigo aí 30 40 50 anos de
dados de um mesmo assunto de um mesmo
tema
bom vamos lá para dar um exemplo vou
pensar um pouquinho algum processo
judicial
a separação guarda
e as informações que a gente precisa
para fazer a o julgamento daquele desse
tema são muito parecidas então 40 50
anos de dados de si mesmo problema criam
padrões de comportamento
e junto com a inteligência artificial eu
posso fazer com que o computador ou a
máquina tome a decisão
é parece meio estranho isso mas pasmo
nos estados unidos isso já está sendo
testado e o que é mais legal o índice
superior a noventa e cinco porcento
e já acuracidade na decisão que o
computador toma e que o juiz toma
e agora se a gente levar isso para a
área da saúde na medicina diagnóstica
por exemplo
se você vende agrupar um conjunto de
dados sobre determinada doença e
consegui antecipar o diagnóstico um
diagnóstico mais precoce quanto tempo a
gente vai ganhar
e aí antecipar o tratamento será que não
vai ser possível salvar um conjunto
maior de vidas
e a gente ainda tem a realidade virtual
o a realidade aumentada que pode colocar
a gente em lugares estamos aqui eu posso
visitar um apartamento em são paulo
conhecer canto por canto cômodo por
cômodo estamos aqui com óculos
e eu posso consertar o equipamento
estando muito longe dele enxergando o
equipamento ali na minha frente a
e agora eu vou falar um pouquinho da
revolução que eu considero o da
tecnologia que eu considero a mais
importante é impressionante de todas
porque ela não mexe só em questões
virtuais ela vai mexer fisicamente não
só nas empresas
a manufatura aditiva talvez esse nome
sou um pouco estranho mas se eu falar
impressão 3d muita gente vai conhecer
é só é aquela lógica da nossa impressão
comprimento largura da nossa folha de
papel na impressora de casa e a gente
começa a imprimir comprimento largura e
altura
oi e a gente começa a fabricar coisas a
partir da impressão os processos de
fabricação tradicionais necessitam 3458
máquinas
e eu vou conseguir fazer a mesma coisa
com uma máquina só
se você já imaginaram o que que isso
pode causar
e em termos de mudança
e para as empresas de produção e
principalmente os modelos de negócios
e a produção vai ser muito mais rápida
eu consigo pela liberdade geométrica que
tem a impressão 3d
as formas diferentes menos uso de
material menos peso e por consequência
menos custo
se eu consigo hoje tirar peças de uma
impressora e montar um avião numa linha
de montagem sim vocês hoje voavam em
aviões com peças impressas em 3d
o desenvolvimento de produto nem se fala
a redução do tempo de desenvolvimento
chega a setenta por cento e a redução de
custo em mais de cinquenta por cento
e isso é uma baita vantagem para aquelas
empresas
e inovadoras
o que tem o seu corn a inovação
e agora já pensaram na modalidade de
negócio
hoje eu não preciso mais produzir o
produto
e eu posso produzir a digitalização do
produto o desenho do produto
hoje eu não preciso mais transportar
esse produto físico até o consumidor ou
cliente final
e eu posso simplesmente enviar o desenho
se o cliente final tiver impressora
imprime lá
se você imaginar o impacto que a gente
vai causar na logística eu não preciso
mais de um caminhão de uma van de um
navio ou de um avião
e eu simplesmente jogo essa informação
na nuvem ela é impressa aonde ela vai
ser consumida
e agora a parte mais interessante desse
negócio tá na medicina
ver se eu consigo imprimir metal
cerâmica plástico madeira
e tem gente que consegue imprimir tecido
humano
é isso eu consegui imprimir tecido
humano eu consigo fazer um coração
pulmão
é ruim e a fila de transplante como é
que fica
hoje eu não preciso mais esperar o
doador compatível eu simplesmente
escaneio vejo que eu preciso fazer
imprimo
e vai melhorar muito
ah mas tudo isso só vai funcionar se a
gente tiver a última das tecnologias que
compõem todo esse conjunto que é a
segurança da informação ou aquilo que a
gente entende como cyber segurança
e eu preciso garantir com que as
empresas mantenham seus segredos
industriais isso a gente tem que
desenvolver
e agora que eu falei um pouquinho dessas
tecnologias eu tenho que fazer um
mea-culpa eu menti para vocês por duas
vezes a primeira quando eu disse que eu
ia levar você para dar um passeio no
futuro
e eu não tirei vocês daqui
olá tudo isso que eu falei não tem nada
de futuro
e durante seis anos eu tô pesquisando
isso eu enxerguei cada uma dessas coisas
em toda essa tecnologia é agora e a
segunda que eu não vou precisar trazer
ninguém de volta porque nenhum momento
você saíram daqui
e agora é óbvio isso tudo pode causar
uma reação de medo será que isso vai
fazer eu perder o meu emprego será que
eu vou ter que aprender tudo de novo eu
não vou mentir é claro que sim todo
mundo vai ter que reaprender
requalificar se reinventar agora
o emprego
há muitos vão desaparecer e muitos vão
surgir
o emprego os que existiam funções cargos
que existiam há 30 anos atrás são os
mesmos que existem hoje e provavelmente
não vão ser os mesmos que vão existir
daqui a 20 30 anos
e o importante é a gente entender que a
tecnologia ela não vai substituir o ser
humano a tecnologia vai sim trabalhar
junto com o ser humano
e ela é uma aliada ela é do bem ela não
é do mal
e a tecnologia todos nós temos que
entender que ela é um meio e não um fim
e ela nos ajuda
e ela nos ajuda na tomada de decisão em
sermos mais produtivos e facilitar nossa
vida
o ok então quer dizer que agora todo
mundo tem que jogar os seus negócios
para esse lado mais digital
eu acredito que não e a gente tem vários
exemplos que nos remetem a voltar ao
passado
e hortas orgânicas
e doces artesanais um monte de gente
voltando a lojas mais antigas e
comprando lp que talvez muita gente aqui
nem saiba o que é
esse é um movimento de volta ao passado
de talvez uma fatia da população que não
se adaptou às mudanças tecnológicas e
quê tá achando o sustento empreendendo
em outro lugar e com certeza agregando
muito mais valor
é mais claro eu vou ter um conjunto de
empresas que vai precisar e por esse
caminho
bom e quando entrar não tem mais volta
e a competitividade vai aumentar e eu
preciso entender
bom então prato complementar e fechar
isso que eu tentei trazer um pouquinho
para vocês
e eu queria provocar
e agora que você sabem que a tecnologia
não é mais papo de futuro que não é
ficção científica
e qual vai ser o teu próximo passo
bom obrigado
e aí